so what you guys want to do at selena
gomez is tick-tock with me
[Music]
lizzo and selena gomez are ruling the
tick tock world together like damn this
is a big deal yes it is lizzo the singer
duetted a vid the actress posted to her
account over the weekend selena was
taking part in this tick-tock trend
where people mirror a kind of bizarre
animated dance to lizzo's latest hit
with cardi b rumors
selena teamed up with her friend and
little sister gracie for their
recreation
[Music]
that right there is selena showing off
her best moves as her sister's backup
dancer not long after the clip went live
lizzo hit up cell's comment section with
okay i'm doing mines now and boy did she
deliver
so what you guys want to do at selena
gomez's tick tock with me 80 000 of
y'all we got to do that for selena gomez
lizzo up the ante doing the trend from
an actual stage during her set at the
global citizen live event on saturday in
new york city with the help of the crowd
can you see me
are we about to do this oh my god
[Applause]
i love it now lizzo and selena are no
strangers to going viral on tick tock
the rare beauty founder and her little
sis have been making a lot of videos
lately including this full house
reenactment in july i'm older i'm
younger i'm taller i'm stronger i'm
smarter i'm
not falling for that that video has
34.6 million views and counting oh baby
and as for lizzo well she's been busy
trying to shoot her shot with chris
evans on tick tock
this is something that i've been really
trying to keep
personal and private just between me and
the father of my child but
since we're airing out all the rumors
today
[Music]
i've been sucking in
gonna have a little america
now she's not pregnant with his baby but
captain america himself did respond to
the singer's hilarious video i'm feeling
good as hell
lizzo shared what appears to be a dm
from the actor who seemingly wrote quote
hi just heard about our little bundle of
joy my mother will be so happy lol it
shook me up and it gets better because
chris added this funny request quote
just promise me no gender reveal parties
lol
i'm still sweating
okay i'm excited back in 2019 lizzo
opened up to e.t about dating and why
she thinks it makes sense for
celebrities to romance one another it's
like really hard to kind of siphon
through like the [ __ ] and find the
real people but i mean even famous
people can be bullshitters so i don't
know i might just have to marry myself
again
that's another music video